[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUIQUE TOLOZA:
I'm Quique Toloza,
and at the McGovern Institute,
I use computer models
to study the brain.
When I was in middle
school, I put together
my first computer out
of spare components
we had lying around the house.
I was really into
video games and wanted
to play on my own PC.
Video games are actually why
I first got into programming.
I wanted to change the rules
of those virtual worlds
to fit my imagination.
I would spend hours
trying to reverse engineer
how little simple snippets of
code interacted with each other
to make the characters on the
screen behave the way they did.
It's really not that
different from what I do now.
I build computer models
to try to understand
how and why the brain
works the way it does.
And there's a beautiful
and often challenging
thing about working
with code in this way.
Just like in the
best video games,
the main limit to what I can
create is my own imagination.
[MUSIC PLAYING]